Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
La prima volta in cui ricordo
di aver desiderato qualcosa,
avevo all'incirca 10 anni.
Desideravo tantissimo una bambola,
si chiamava Poldina.
Non un capriccio, intendiamoci bene,
ma uno di quei desideri
che ha bisogno del tempo dell'attesa.
Da lì, per tutta la vita
ho continuato a desiderare
cose piccole e grandi.
Micro e macro, diremmo stasera:
ma la dimensione
del desiderio poco importa.
Per capire meglio
di cosa parliamo questa sera,
partiamo dall'origine del nome:
cosa significa desiderio?
Da dove deriva?
Nasce dal latino "de-sidera":
"de-", privativo, mancanza;
"Mancanza di stelle"
Wow! Il desiderio è una mancanza.
Io inizio a desiderare
quando mi manca qualcosa,
quando mi mancano le stelle.
Allora cosa faccio?
Provo ad acchiappare le stelle,
faccio di tutto, mi metto in moto,
perché le stelle
le voglio avere, mi mancano.
Questa è stata un po' la nostra vita,
la nostra vita è stata segnata
da questo desiderio.
Io e Dario, compagni dell'università,
sebbene facessimo cose diverse
ci siamo trovati a vivere
una di quelle "amicizie per la vita",
un'amicizia segnata, però,
da una mancanza.
Il nostro amico Marco, che vedete,
muore a soli 24 anni.
Questa mancanza
è quello che ci ha fatto scoprire
il desiderio di costruire
qualcosa per gli altri.
Siamo rimasti amici,
ciascuno di noi ha fatto cose diverse,
abbiamo lavorato in campi diversi,
ci siamo sposati,
le nostre famiglie da sempre
fanno le vacanze insieme;
ma non abbiamo mai perso
quel desiderio di costruire.
Finché, nel '94,
abbiamo deciso che valeva la pena
iniziare a lavorare insieme.
In che campo?
Ricordo che parlavamo, ed entrambi
sentivamo una ferita, uno struggimento
a pensare a quei giovani
che avevano invece perso il desiderio,
diremmo tecnicamente
"destinati a una marginalità sociale",
quei giovani che avevano fatto
a botte con la scuola.
Allora abbiamo deciso
che valeva la pena
mettere le mani in pasta.
Abbiamo provato
a mettere le mani in pasta;
e tutto nasce da questo desiderio
di cui parla Cristiana,
ma è un desiderio che negli anni -
sono oltre 30 anni che ci dedichiamo
a questa avventura -
negli anni questo desiderio è cresciuto,
incontrando decine
di migliaia di adolescenti,
in cui si vedeva emergere
con potenza, in loro, questo desiderio.
Abbiamo cercato di accompagnarli:
abbiamo cercato di accompagnarli
nelle attività educative,
nell'inserimento lavorativo.
Mentre li accompagnavamo,
cercavamo di stare attenti
per capire quali erano i problemi
più importanti che c'erano.
E ce n'erano tanti:
ma uno dei più importanti che ci colpiva,
come dice Cristiana, che ci feriva,
era che dopo un po' di tempo
che lavoravano,
molti di questi ragazzi
perdevano il lavoro.
Allora, abbiamo cominciato a chiederci:
cosa possiamo fare?
Questa domanda è rimasta lì
per un po' di tempo, per un po' di anni.
Poi, un giorno, era il 2003,
squilla il telefono, ed era Cristiana.
Cristiana era in Spagna,
stava seguendo un progetto
transnazionale europeo,
e mi dice: "Dario, ho trovato l'idea:
ho trovato un luogo
dove l'aspetto educativo
e il lavoro stanno insieme."
Allora la sua passione educativa -
lei è l'anima educativa
della Piazza dei Mestieri -
e la mia passione imprenditoriale -
volevo fare l'imprenditore già da piccolo,
ho messo su un po' di cose -
si mettono all'opera.
In breve tempo troviamo un luogo,
una vecchia conceria di 7500 metri quadri.
Siamo nel 2004, nasce
la "Piazza dei Mestieri".
Come vedete questa è la foto
della corte della Piazza dei Mestieri,
che però, simbolicamente,
fa capire qual era l'idea di fondo.
Da un lato, a sinistra,
il luogo dove i ragazzi si incontrano
tra di loro, e con i loro insegnanti.
A destra, la stessa piazza
completamente diversa la sera,
quando diventa una piazza aperta
alla città, alle famiglie,
agli imprenditori -
è un pub.
Cosa succede?
Per ogni attività educativa,
abbiamo aperto un'attività produttiva.
Perché?
Perché volevamo che questi ragazzi
potessero fare, durante
il percorso di studi
dei tre o quattro anni
in cui stanno con noi,
un'esperienza lavorativa vera,
vedessero cosa vuol dire
rispettare i tempi,
cosa vuol dire lavorare in una brigata,
cosa vuol dire servire il cliente,
cioè potessero fare
veramente un'esperienza.
Così, per ciascuna attività produttiva,
da noi producono -
ci sono panettieri, cioccolatieri,
mastri birrai, grafici, informatici,
tanti mestieri;
e per ognuno di questi
c'era un'attività produttiva.
Così, ogni volta che incontriamo
un ragazzo che ha fatto
a botte con la scuola,
come dicevamo prima,
e che decide di cambiare,
decide di seguire il proprio desiderio,
è come se il mio cuore avesse un sussulto,
perché il desiderio è contagioso.
Perché vedi loro cambiare, e dici:
"In fondo, io desidero la stessa cosa".
Guardate, ho avuto una vita bellissima,
ho fatto degli incontri straordinari;
ma la tentazione, alla nostra età,
di sederci e vedere la vita passare
è sempre in agguato.
Questo non lo vogliamo fare:
allora stiamo con questi ragazzi,
e continuiamo ad imparare
da loro e dal loro desiderio.
La piazza si è trasformata
come quelle di una volta,
che avevamo in mente.
L'abbiamo chiamata così
perché abbiamo pensato ai mestieri,
all'abilità delle mani degli artigiani,
all'intelligenza delle mani.
Ma perché abbiamo pensato a un luogo
in cui ci si potesse incontrare
tra generazioni diverse,
tra etnie diverse, culture diverse,
e si potesse stare insieme
a imparare un mestiere.
Man mano, abbiamo aggiunto dei pezzi
a questo puzzle che si stava componendo.
Il puzzle da cosa era composto?
Man mano, dai bisogni,
perché incontrando un ragazzo
incontravamo la sua famiglia,
i suoi genitori,
e diventava sempre più complesso.
Ma ci ha sempre guidato una parola,
quella della bellezza.
Voi, qui, vedete
"La bellezza salverà il mondo":
è la scritta che c'è all'entrata
del nostro ristorante,
una frase di Dostoevskij.
Ma cos'è la bellezza?
La bellezza è proprio quella cosa
che permette di tenere desto il desiderio.
Io non cambio perché ci sono delle regole.
Ci vogliono, per l'amor del cielo;
ma cambio perché c'è
qualcosa che mi attrae,
qualcosa che mi affascina,
la bellezza che mi conquista.
Così sono nati, nel tempo,
oltre alle attività produttive,
dei concorsi.
Facciamo tantissimi concorsi,
fino a un concorso di poesia,
riservato a quelle che chiameremmo
scuole di serie B, o scuole professionali,
aperto ai ragazzi di tutta Italia.
Rassegne di musica jazz, teatro:
insomma, la piazza è diventata,
per i nostri ragazzi, una casa.
Una casa, si può dire anche un luogo,
dove abbiamo visto in questi anni,
in un modo impressionante e commovente,
vedersi riaccendere il desiderio;
e soprattutto vedere molti ragazzi,
che magari arrivavano
da piccolini, un po' timidi,
tante volte con situazioni difficili,
vedere risorgere in loro una stima di sé,
ricominciare a dire "io valgo".
Avere stima di sé,
avere stima del talento
di cui la natura ci ha dotati
è importantissimo nella vita,
e nella vita di un adolescente.
Così, un po' per volta,
questo entusiasmo dei nostri ragazzi
ha trascinato tutti,
come diceva anche Cristiana.
Le famiglie,
che spesso sono distanti dalla scuola
e nel rapporto coi giovani,
hanno cominciato a ricoinvolgersi
in questa avventura.
Innanzitutto, nell'avventura
dei loro figli.
Poi le scuole e le imprese.
Quest'idea del connubio
tra lavoro, educazione e formazione -
Sentiamo ogni giorno
che ci sono tante imprese
che cercano profili di lavoro
che non trovano:
ma bisogna investire su questo,
sennò lo diremo per i prossimi 30 anni
e sarà sempre così.
Abbiamo deciso di investire
coinvolgendo le imprese,
coinvolgendole dal momento
in cui progettiamo i percorsi,
nell'accompagnamento dei ragazzi.
In piazza, questo
ha scatenato la creatività:
si incontrano le generazioni.
Le nostre ragazze
del percorso di acconciatura,
pettinando gratuitamente,
una volta alla settimana,
le signore anziane del quartiere,
ascoltano le loro storie,
della guerra, del dopoguerra,
della ricostruzione.
Si appassionano,
vanno a chiamare i loro compagni
di grafica della comunicazione, e dicono:
"Dobbiamo fissare queste storie,
dobbiamo ricordarcele."
Alla fine fanno uno spettacolo teatrale
che abbiamo portato in giro per l'Italia.
Un modo, come diceva Cristiana, diverso
di affrontare l'aspetto educativo.
Noi avevamo tre classi
che facevano casino, sostanzialmente,
per cui gli insegnanti
facevano fatica a tenerle.
Ma uno di questi insegnanti,
che faceva il corso di cucina,
era uno che amava la musica,
aveva delle band eccetera;
e decide di dire, a questi ragazzi:
"Facciamo una band".
Fanno una band di tamburini,
a cui si aggiungeranno poi le trombe.
Ve la faccio breve: dopo poco tempo,
questa band viene chiamata
dalla città di Torino
a sfilare al 1° maggio.
L'importante non è solo questo,
che ovviamente li ha resi orgogliosi,
ma che questo li ha ributtati
dentro lo studio,
ha fatto tornare loro
la passione per lo studio.
Ma non è una casa solo per chi ci sta:
è una casa a cui si può tornare.
Tante volte succede che arrivano,
come è successo un mese fa circa,
ero davanti al portone della corte,
due ragazze arrivano e dicono:
"Abbiamo perso il lavoro".
Erano uscite dalla Piazza
dei Mestieri dieci anni prima.
"Abbiamo perso il lavoro,
siamo molto tristi;
ma non siamo disperate,
perché c'è la Piazza dei Mestieri".
Non è che risolviamo i problemi a tutti,
né tantomeno troviamo il lavoro a tutti.
Ma è l'idea che non sei da solo,
che c'è un punto.
Oppure quelli che vengono
a raccontarci, orgogliosi,
i loro successi:
i ragazzi che stanno in giro
nei grandi ristoranti,
in Italia o nel mondo.
Oppure, il ragazzo che è arrivato
l'anno scorso in finale ad Amici,
e ha potuto coltivare
la sua passione per la musica.
Poi, tante storie pazzesche:
un giorno in cui troveremo il tempo
proveremo a scrivere queste storie,
fissare anche noi
nella memoria queste storie,
come quella di una ragazza,
una ragazza madre che -
un giorno arriva nel cortile della Piazza
con una carrozzina,
era appena nato il suo bambino.
Tutti le vanno intorno, le dicono:
"Ciao, che bel bambino. Come mai sei qua?"
Lei risponde:
"Perché in questo posto sono stata amata,
perché in questo posto
ho imparato ad amare,
ho visto la bellezza,
e volevo che la prima cosa
che vedesse mio figlio
fosse questa cosa bella."
(Applausi)
All'entrata della nostra scuola,
del nostro luogo,
c'è questo striscione:
"Un luogo che muove la vita".
Come si fa a muovere la vita?
Com'è possibile che accadano le cose
che ha raccontato un attimo fa Dario?
Ci vuole una passione.
Ci vogliono degli adulti
che hanno il desiderio
di trasmettere questa passione.
Deve essere una passione diffusa,
perché l'anno scorso, tra le nostre sedi
di Torino, Catania e adesso Milano,
sono passati oltre 5000 giovani.
Io e Dario non potremmo certo
incontrarli tutti;
allora ci dobbiamo affidare ai docenti,
a quei docenti straordinari
che ogni mattina, attraverso l'appello,
chiedono ai nostri ragazzi,
guardandoli negli occhi uno per uno,
di essere lì presenti,
di imparare a usare le mani intelligenti;
e contemporaneamente,
continuare a desiderare,
desiderare di cambiare.
E lo imparano con lo sguardo.
Il docente è un mestiere straordinario:
Sono 30 anni che non entro
in una classe tradizionale
a insegnare italiano,
ma continuo a considerarmi una prof,
perché insegnare vuol dire
lasciare un segno, dare un pezzo di sé.
E così sono i nostri docenti
che entrano nelle aule.
Come dicevamo prima,
i nostri docenti entrano nelle aule
e non dicono come devono essere,
o cosa devono fare, i nostri ragazzi:
li sfidano.
Sfidano la loro libertà,
sfidano la loro responsabilità.
Ma c'è sempre, come sappiamo,
nella nostra storia, nella mia,
in quella di Cristiana,
credo nella storia di tutti noi,
un momento in cui nella vita
sorge un nemico, che si chiama paura.
Ti prende paura:
e allora resti bloccato,
e serve qualcosa per vincere la paura.
Per vincere la paura
serve un amico, serve un maestro,
come ci ricorda Dante
in quel pezzo bellissimo,
quando sta per iniziare il suo viaggio.
Si trova davanti alle porte
dell'Inferno, e si ferma.
Non avrebbe il coraggio di andare avanti
se di fianco a lui non ci fosse
il suo maestro Virgilio, il suo amico.
Come dice Dante:
"Poiché la sua mano alla mia
pose con lieto volto,
ond'io mi confortai,
mi mise dentro alle segrete cose"
Cioè mi mise dentro la realtà.
Avete visto l'immagine di Tino,
il nostro pasticciere, il maestro;
e questa è una mano che aiuta i ragazzi
a entrare nella sfida della vita.
Non sono risparmiate fatiche a nessuno,
per l'amor del cielo;
ma questa mano ti può sorreggere
in certi momenti.
Così la nostra piazza
è diventata una storia di storie,
come abbiamo visto.
Ciascuna particolare,
e diversa da tutte le altre;
ma tutte unite da questo sottile filo,
come è già stato detto
in altri momenti, prima di noi.
L'energia che noi
sentiamo qui questa sera,
e che sentiamo entrando in Piazza,
nasce sempre quando ci rendiamo conto
che la nostra vita non è inutile,
che questo momento che stiamo vivendo
non è inutile.
Questa percezione ci apre a una sfida,
come diceva prima Dario,
ma soprattutto a una responsabilità,
e a un compito.
Vogliamo ringraziarvi,
ed è un'emozione, sinceramente,
essere qui stasera, essere qui con voi.
Siamo molto grati
di essere stati invitati,
perché è stata una sfida per noi.
Ma noi diciamo sempre ai nostri ragazzi:
"Voi dovete accettarla".
Non si può educare
se non ci si lascia educare,
quindi abbiamo voluto
raccogliere quella sfida.
Voglio dire una cosa, l'ultima,
in particolare a tutti i giovani
che sono qui questa sera,
e che ci ascoltano.
Non abbiate paura dei desideri
più profondi del vostro cuore,
cercate le tante mani amiche
che noi abbiamo trovato.
Perché vi auguro che a 60 anni, come noi,
possiate dire che la vita
vale veramente la pena di essere vissuta.
Perché le forze, diceva qualcuno,
che cambiano la Storia,
sono le stesse che cambiano
il cuore dell'uomo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)